[Music]
I guess I've always want to ask this
about comedy do you think it's better to
be smart or charming in comedy it's
weird like people you have to be smart
but like not like to ous about like
saying the word ostentatious for that
would be a good example of you not want
to do it's a great Woody Allen quote
where he says smart comedians always
downplay their intelligence and and dum
ones are the any any comedian who's
successful is probably really smart I
I'm not saying one way or the other but
like is Buddy hacket smart I bet he's
Street Smart Street Smart quick yeah
quick a kind of smart now we're talking
but you know that would be the opposite
is [__] okay this what I mean there
I'm going to go on a Lim and say there
are no successful [__]
comedians all right everybody's in
family pot let's go deal it up family
pot is the lingo family pot means
everybody's in got I'm going to bet I'll
bet $125 all right oh up in the anti too
much he has something good I don't think
that's upping the antie see the thing is
he's using just the the sort of
expression upping the antie but when you
actually use it at a table it sort of
has you
like when you make a part five and
you're like well that's part of the
cool the most awful things I've ever
seen people dip Doritos into nacho
cheese it's already nacho cheese
flavored and C what you I love that we
need to get this out of the open Chris
has really weird like food
issues first of all he barely eats
anything he won't touch anything that's
a vegetable he's he's he's scared of
soup or something not true didn't you
say on on stage that the closest thing
you'll eat to soup is
cereal just nothing like I think I like
soup what what don't you like sou uh I
don't like
soup Queen oh you have two pair he never
knows what he has he doesn't know what
he has to be fair when that King came
out I don't think he realized this but
itm three hearts there was a flush
there's a straight there all kinds of
things yeah he was not considering that
he wasn't yeah but you made me sick
poker you're wearing glasses but you're
the stupidest person here why this is
really fun I didn't think it'd be this
fun people
[Music]
say have you guys ever accidentally
stole someone's joke and not even yeah
definitely and you know what I did it
better than them a lot better you know
what the thing is I realized is that
there's really only like four or five
funny ideas floating around in the
universe so the chances of you like
doing the same joke as somebody else are
going to
pretty high I mean Sim are wait hold on
are you kidding or you no I'm serious I
really think I would say there's a good
chance that like each of us probably has
like some jokes in our act that somebody
else somewhere does and just because
nobody's ever seen it we don't know
there there's a couple pillars there's
wealth Health um what else there's race
doesn't rhyme with wealth I've heard
that I've heard there's seven jokes you
know there's only seven jokes out there
you're saying that my my what I thought
was an original idea that there are no
original ideas you're saying even that
is not an original idea oh my God my
face is about to swallow
itself but a lot of your face has to do
with how you are as a comic all the time
look at Laurel and Hardy you know which
one is which if you've only heard a
record of them then you saw a photo of
them you'd know which was which I wonder
if Jordan's going to talk about being
like kind of a prey black guy you know
what I mean you can tell that Matt
goldage is going to do kind of low-key
snide observational humor I thought he
was going to do all poop
stuff it's 50 cents he made it 50 I'm
sorry it's at this
table the numbers 15 and 50 sound so
similar I think we should call it fitty
cuz how many times were you be like what
time do we meet 10:15 1050 no 10:15 who
ranges to meet at 10:50 a lot of people
in comedy where you're like it's an open
mic when do you sign up
7:15 how much time have we lost
clarifying just go to F we've lost no
time and I'll tell
you but then also people will be like
did you just say F when do you need 50
cc's of something and they give you 15
and you die your last thoughts are going
to be me going we should have said fitty
great example of another thing that will
never happen Okay that
you the I was on a plane I was on a
plane flying to uh Georgia and the guy
next to me goes like what do they give
us like five peanuts
now like this is a hack conversation I
had to be like I'm giving you the light
yeah hey do you guys see the similarity
between the comedy boom and the current
poker boom that they show neither of
them are very
funny